The COVID-19 pandemic
will have a huge effect
on Thanksgiving this year.
A lot of families will not
travel and gather together,
but what about the ones that will?
Amazon's created a brand
new echo device with Alexa
built just for this
year's family gatherings.
Take a look.
I'm gonna need a Xanax to prepare me
for what your mother's gonna
say at the dinner table.
Don't worry, Alexa's on it.
Huh?
Mm, stuffing's great babe.
Thanks.
You know what's not great?
This damn China virus,
and the lockdown's worse than the disease.
[Alexa] Hey, who's in the mood
for some celebrity trivia?
Yes please.
I am!
[Narrator] Just in time
for what's sure to be a
stressful family Thanksgiving,
it's the new Amazon Echo,
with subject-changing Alexa.
[Alexa] Did you know that Ryan Gosling
and Sandra Bullock once dated?
I did not know that,
I'm just looking forward
to Trump's second
inauguration on January 20th.
Okay.
[Alexa] Speaking of presidents,
did you know that President
Theodore Roosevelt
had a pet hyena?
Oh.
Hey kids, who would like a pet hyena?
Me, I do!
Me, me!
Thanks Alexa.
[Mom] Mom does too.
[Narrator] Amazon Echo,
with subject-changing Alexa,
your most important
guest this Thanksgiving.